[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça arrive comme un pays
sur une toile cirée est de qualité
capillaire c'est la firme avec la
machine
j'ai laissé seydoux et le cc loup
lapointe et ôté un poids en forme en toi
enfin bon on va être dans les dégradés
miquel c'est l'un des meilleurs dès
lundi des défilés non je suis pas
d'accord je dégage non je te dit tout
regarde là regardez la belle a eu plein
il ya une chose qu'on appelle une zone
non déroger c'est ce que je fais
pourtant comédie je t'adore j'ai bon
sens
alors en avant que tu n'es pas en avant
s'est pas loupé la côte du rhône un
service est-ce que tu prêt d'oublier un
peu les vôtres et des métros devant
youtube l'espère on attend on est ce
qu'on peut m'amener un tee shirt
j'ai bien varié
alors c'est que fait des gosses défaut
car sur la tête de ma vie sa voix est
cent fois mieux qu'au match là bas après
tout à fait leur travail mais a laissé
peu de tourner vers kakuma à bassam a
fuck charles vannson au club c'est comme
ça que je suis pressé tout le temps qu
il fallait que je mette à consommer mais
tu m'as coûte pour on va travailler tout
ce qu'ils ont raté au moins ça va 5
minutes et black metal la dose est
[Rires]
vraiment celle intrigues du live
ça ouvre les portes
une blague comment voyez-vous des visas
comme ce qu'on dit c'est que ça ouvrira
la mairie de préférence parce que si
vous prenez l'eau du robinet les cas
l'intérieur ça te coûte 87 comtois ça
coûte cher ça coûte cher
on referme ici comme ceci voilà on met
la petite capsule ici et là il ya la
fumée qui va sortir
hélas à petit la peur la peur l'affût de
l'accord exactement normalement on
enlève le masque encore déjà une
sensation déjà bien d'être assez valse
c'est chaud
oui si moi je dis non c'est pas ça colle
des fils après ces bruits votre chance à
pas toi moi et me tirer après quoi sert
le fait les alley 10 disent rien mais ce
genre d'écart alors cdj alors toi on va
on va l'adapter pour moi
[Musique]
c'est toi c'est un peu tard et rassemble
pas cette fois sur la bêta oui cette
fois chez toi sur la table et yaskawa
pas ça elle est exceptionnelle je n'en
suis pas fier j'ai pris chez non non tu
sais qu'on va arrêter là dessus c'est
déjà les i j'ai bien banale histoire
alors que vous dire s'est avouée à
moitié pardonnée
à noter qu'apple aurait pu ne pas vous
le dire
j'aurai plus de fantaisie allez vas-y
rit je suis dans les vallées bah oui
c'est que je suis au moins du coup bas
[Applaudissements]